these guys do some things defensively
coming off pin downs as you see right
here man look at this coming off the pit
down quick catch a chute right there
here's Hiro this guy
it didn't look off the dribble - I got a
wet ball heat the flamethrower as you
can see here he goes again put a
blindfold on this guy the rebound was
pulled by while or bath by Tyler hero
and a 12 point lead for the heat
what do you laugh at that Quran
I've always looking at the reaction of
Pat Riley air exposed to over here with
the Euro step to dump off two hands for
safety
exposed to over here with the Euro step
to dump off two hands for safety
[Music]
everytime hero catches the basketball
and start dribbling around something's
good is going to happen using this all
paint 14 points off in this heat lead
tower hero tipped Robin Yount team Aten
and Chris Silva officials Brandon is
[Applause]
down to three on the shot clock
Kendrick from Wisconsin haha he can
really shoot big brothers when you talk
about guys that you idolize when you
come into the Association that I'm gonna
teach you how to be a true and just see
a tree Hornet over there while
rebounding finishing terrific college
basketball player let's see what you can
do in the pro kendrick none is sizzling
out here there are some open spots on
the depth chart for the heat
[Music]
John's left alone did they not get the
memo confused riveting first quarter
between two undefeated teams the heat
and rules at three and oh and here's
Kansas again of seven from the field on
that move right there Rick
I initially looked over at coach
Spoelstra as he's going downhill
Robinson got his thoughts together one
caught that ball are you kidding
[Applause]
where Miss got it back put it right in I
mean it's his day right you have to be a
straight was crafty if it McLaughlin
they give it to the pain and be able to
fit it over the side not use that pic
from Aten answer 83 81 Miami so no need
to foul here for Miami just play some
[Applause]
affiliates follow on a play we are tied
[Applause]
he's a type of guy that Miami Heat
will love to have look at this he
embodies the culture he's gonna strap up
go get it the hard way get a steal get
out of transition Jew hands for safety
if it I'm a pound my chance to get the
crowd excited what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content